le conseil départemental en partenariat
avec le cnfpt ont organisé une journée
d'actualité ce lundi 13 juin d'un
du palais de la source un séminaire sur
la loi du 14 mars 2016 relative à la
protection de l'enfance
en fait la loi de 2016 et en venir
compléter renforcer la loi 2007 dès
qu'elle réaffirme aujourd'hui le rôle
fondamental du département de la
protection de l'enfance elle insiste sur
une meilleure identification des
problèmes un meilleur repérage des
risques mais également comment mieux
sécuriser la notion de parcours de
l'enfant
le deuxième point majeur et ceux du bien
et vit de la prévention comment
renforcer l'accompagnement en amour les
familles car en sorte de proposer des
mesures alternatives dans le cadre
administratif dans le cadre de
l'accompagnement des familles avant
d'arriver à un placement judiciaire est
le troisième point est celui la place de
la santé donc la loi insiste beaucoup
sur la nécessité d'avoir un médecin
référant au niveau de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance 197 travailleurs sociaux
étaient présents afin d'oeuvrer ensemble
à une véritable réforme de la protection
de l'enfance bon donc beaucoup
d'améliorations le coût de travail
puisque effectivement le bilan qui a été
fait de la loi de l'es7 ce matin -
effectivement d'un certain nombre
l'objectif de terre ou recherché à
travers m
cet été est suffisamment ratait
moussoulens et après la mise à l'eau en
2016 effectivement on a un peu accentué
ses démarches sur le terrain pour
justement faire en sorte que les
objectifs qui sont sensiblement les
mêmes je dirais puisse être peu comme en
chine que ce que j'attends donc de la
loi de 2016 c'est que vraiment ils
viennent donner ou département des
modalités donc pratique pour pouvoir
mettre en place et en oeuvre des
dispositions qui avait déjà été validé
par la loi de 2007 et qui n'ont pas pu
la faute donc deux décrets suffisamment
explicite être mise en place en fait par
le département
une réunion de travail qui a permis de
faire le bilan sur l'ancienne mois de
2007 et de définir les enjeux et les
attentes de la nouvelle loi de 2016 mais
aussi de déterminer les répercussions à
la fois pour le travail social et la
politique de la protection de l'enfance